systems and so the next talk will be
given by nathan louise who's going to
tell us about ways you can use quantum
computers to understand properties of
quantum systems
thanks a lot Andrew so yeah I'm really
excited to be here and get a chance to
talk to you guys about you know probably
what I'm most excited about in quantum
computing which is simulating physical
systems and so I think this is this is
going to hopefully will be a very useful
talk because well later on today we've
got Ryan talking about quantum
simulation algorithms for chemistry a
lot of the methods that he's going to be
talking about will be directly using the
ideas that I'm presenting here so it's
at least my hope that it'll make many of
the ideas that he presents in that
second talk much clearer also because
we've got a relatively small audience
feel free to interrupt me at any time I
really would rather you know people in
the audience get something out of this
talk rather than necessarily get exposed
to all ideas at a level of detail that I
thought you know in my cording to my
prior would be reasonable so great so
just to give you an idea about what I'm
hoping to talk about here the main point
that I want to discuss is I really want
to give you an idea about what are the
sorts of things that people have been
thinking about and exploring over the
last couple of years in quantum
simulation and in particular I'm going
to be talking about three main
techniques that I think are very
important for people to have at least
heard about in quantum simulation the
first and most and easiest of these is
charter based methods for quantum
simulation then linear combinations of
unit Ares methods and all finally qubit
ization these names will make a little
bit more sense I can't guarantee they'll
make a hundred percent sense but they
make a little bit more sense by the time
I make to the end but one of the things
first things that I that's going to be
very important especially in the context
of the last talk is to really clearly
discuss what we mean by quantum
simulation many of us come from
different communities and many of us use
the term quantum simulation and have a
very strong view about what this ends up
meaning and each field I find uses it
differently so the the weight view I'm
going to be using for quantum simulation
it's often going to be the the view that
quantum computer scientists often take
for simulation so as opposed to looking
at static
properties which people usually look at
in you know DMR G tensor networks things
like this the primary focus is going to
be Undine Amex because curiously
dynamics are the more natural thing to
simulate on a quantum computer for most
algorithms than statics so just to give
you an idea why do we care about quantum
simulation well alright I resisted the
temptation to give the standard Fineman
slide here but quantum simulation really
was sort of the first natural
application of quantum quantum computing
in fact in many ways it sort of is the
natural application for it because if
you think about it what does it mean to
have a universal quantum computer a
universal quantum computer is a device
that's capable of performing any unitary
transformation on a set of qubits that's
the that's it or at least approximately
approximating it and so if you look at
what quantum physics describes for the
dynamics of quantum states
it describes dynamics as a unitary
evolution on a quantum state so then the
task of quanta simulating a system is
really just a task of compiling that
unitary that nature gives you down to a
set of gate operations ok great so now
all of you understand quantum simulation
so any questions
it's very important that the talking
circle policy area
[Music]
sure I mean you know one of the issues
that this is this is a good point that
I'm going to I'm going to yes there are
slides after this don't worry the
question about what the the input model
is and what the assumptions are in the
Hamiltonian are going to be quite
important at some point if you're
interested in doing this on a physical
quantum computer you are going to have
to worry about local interactions
however in the model that I'm discussing
here I'm not going to go into detail
about how to do this precisely in terms
of local operations but that's a good
point so basically that's the idea is
that we really want to be able to
compile quantum dynamics into a sequence
of gates that can be run on a quantum
computer ideally local gates and so this
not only this to me I think is really
neat because if we look at algorithms
like Shor's algorithm that provides you
a speed-up for precisely one class of
problems quantum simulation it's an
entire toolbox there's a host of
different problems that we can solve
with us not just the standard ones you
know and answering questions about
catalysis probing the the question about
what the mechanisms are behind
high-temperature superconductivity but
also these techniques have been used in
a host of other places such as quantum
machine learning algorithms algorithms
for preparing Gibbs States so it
actually really is a fundamental tool
that appears in a bunch of quantum
algorithms and not necessarily just in
its raw application so the form of
Hamiltonian simulation I'm going to be
taking a look at it mostly again it's
dynamical simulation so this
unfortunately doesn't display all that
well so I'll have to pantomime a bit but
basically the idea is is that in imagine
you've got a physical system you're
provided as input some initial state
now that initial state is going to
evolve according to a time evolution
operator e to the minus IHT and it
evolves through some trajectory down to
some final state over there and so what
we want to do is we want to be able to
map this to a quantum computer so
there's several steps in this the first
one we take the initial state and we
just find some encoding to map that to a
quantum bit string in the quan
computer note this quantum computer I've
drawn is bigger than the physical system
and that's often because we need ancilla
qubits to represent it so formally the
hilbert space that describes the quantum
computers often bigger than the hilbert
space of the physical system we're
trying to simulate just because of
overheads but anyways we begin by
encoding that quantum state in the
quantum computer up to some air then
what we do is we do a series of gate
operations that takes it to some other
place in the the Hilbert space then what
we hope is if we've done or compilation
properly this final quantum state in the
system should be logically equivalent to
some state that's within distance
epsilon of the target state for an
epsilon you you proposed before the
algorithm starts so ideally you know you
don't want that epsilon to be one you
want this to be something at yeah that's
programmable and controllable and you
what you'd like to do is you'd like to
have algorithms that for every epsilon
greater than zero can give you a
complexity of getting that state within
distance epsilon so that's the that's
the dynamical simulation problem that
we're interested in looking at here
there's a number of things though that
end up coming in first is well okay how
exactly do we do this compilation
process to map this across obviously
this curve line doesn't give you much
insight on how how that would actually
be done and there's a bunch of
techniques for doing it but there's
another couple of points that I'm
actually I'm gonna spend differing
degrees of discussion on the part of the
discussion that I'm going to I'm going
to spend almost no time on is discussing
how we prepare this in the input the
initial States I of zero into it this
problem is vitally important for
applications like quantum chemistry but
typically when computer scientists end
up looking at this they just take this
as a given like it's some input to the
problem all right and as for the output
the output is formally in quantum
quantum state but in general we don't
want just a quantum state because the
quantum state doesn't provide any
information in and of itself normally
we'd like to learn things about the
quantum states and so the idea basically
is is that often this primitive
algorithm in here for quantum semi
dynamical simulation is just a box
that's going to be running inside a
larger quantum algorithm
you estimates of the things that you're
actually interested in all right so
that's that's basically how it all goes
and yeah so formally we want to be able
to say minimize the for this problem the
norm of the difference between the
evolution in that and of course for all
the methods that we consider for doing
this compilation we'd like to pick the
one that's cheapest so as for the the
input for this now what I what I mean by
the input here is I don't mean the
initial state I really mean if we've got
some black box algorithm it's capable of
simulating Hamiltonian dynamics in
general it best know what the
Hamiltonian is if it doesn't know what
the Hamiltonian is there's something
deeply wrong with your algorithm so
there's a bunch of different models that
you can that you can use for it one of
the easiest ones I think conceptually is
this model I I called it I don't think
it's got a name formally but I'm gonna
call it unitary access here and what the
idea basically is is assuming your
Hamiltonian is a sum of a bunch of
different unitary matrices where these a
J's are just some coefficients so you
might think alright this doesn't sound
all that natural when do you have a
decomposition into a sum of unitary 's
well turns out Pauli operators are
unitary so actually most physics models
that we use to describe describe nature
take this form up here in at least in
the most convenient way for us to
represent it barring that what we can do
is we can take a general Hamiltonian and
decompose it into a sum of unitary
matrices yeah in general but I'll
discuss that later with the next access
model in more detail so all right this
is the specification of the problem
we've got a sum of unitary 's that
comprise the hamiltonian what we need to
be able to do is we need to be able to
apply apply these and compute their
weights so
okay so let me let me just explain then
with that what this means yeah yeah yeah
that's what I that's what I want to say
I so basically what the Select thing
does yeah what that what that the
unitary does is it says it takes an
index J which says which unitary is it
and then it applies that unitary to the
quantum state you want to simulate so
think about it as a programmable
applicator so to speak that ends up yeah
yeah yeah so I so in any case what the
idea basically is is it applies the the
the unitary in question to it so this
just allows you to say for any unitary
let's program ibly apply that one
unitary to the quantum system but that
doesn't give you the AJ's right that
only gives you a way of applying the at
the H J's the way that the AJ's are
accessed is through this prepare circuit
which is a unitary that prepares the
coefficients in a quantum superposition
over there and so these two elements
give you everything that you need in
order to be able to simulate dynamics in
this context and it's very nice to use
in cases where you're simulating
physical systems but this model isn't
actually so convenient from more broad
applications a more broad approach that
is used and actually was popular before
this this top one is it's an approach
that I call the sparse matrix access
model and so the idea basically is
alright assume your matrix doesn't have
any knowin structure a priori nobody
gives it to you as a sum of unitary
matrices but what they tell you
beforehand is that the matrix is d
sparse meaning that there's at most D
nonzero matrix elements in every row and
column and also assume that that the
sparsity pattern is computable so
there's an efficient function that you
can run that'll tell you where exactly
these potentially nonzero matrix
elements are located in every row and so
yeah how the access model works is it
gives you quantum circuits or
boxes that give you the representation
of that function which says where is the
nonzero matrix elements and another
function which tells you what its value
is
sometimes people combine them together
into one kind of you know super black
box but I prefer to separate them so the
basic that's the basic idea behind it
and the final one which I'm not going to
really be dealing with much at all
because mainly because I don't like it
is a density matrix access so in this
model what happens is that Hamiltonian
is literally given to you by a
potentially nonunitary source that gives
you a density matrix and the idea
basically is a density matrix is a
hermitian operator so actually you can
that is effectively a Hamiltonian and so
if you've got act that sort of access
then you can implement ee2 the - I wrote
e so this gives you a way that you can
simulate dense hermitian matrices in in
this fashion and it works ok if you've
got low rank but in general either this
method is really really costly so I I
don't care for it but it's caught it's
commonly used in quantum machine
learning so it's worth knowing about at
the very least alright so then now yeah
great okay so there's no no time in
there so let me let me let me try this
again all that I'm doing is trying to
describe in these is just describing
formally what subroutines provide the
algorithms with the values of the matrix
elements of the Hamiltonian and so
we're gonna freeze time for a little bit
I'm just trying to understand this this
is the Hamiltonian it's being decomposed
yeah so in all of these cases it's the
Hamiltonian that's being written in
different forms and yeah great any other
questions long as you have one sitting
back oh I didn't know that well normally
in general what's what's used is at
least that the standard method that was
used for decomposing this for the the
second approach is that graph coloring
techniques would be used in order to
write the Hamiltonian as a sum of one
sparse matrices
now once bars hermitian matrices are
also unitary so that's that's something
it's also kind of nice about it so the
the draw only drawback of these methods
is that they tended to require a large
number of matrices in a decomposition if
you wanted to do this efficiently but
I'd love to hear about other methods
that could be used for this because yeah
these are called C and main it's very
very important role in mathematics
maybe everyone else loved it maybe I
didn't so you know great thanks so the
okay so that's these are basically how
you get the Hamiltonian in as for the
output really there's a couple of things
that we want usually to get out of this
the first is will often want I can
values will want to know spectral
information about this so the idea
behind this is that what you do is you
use the quantum simulation methods that
I'm going to talk about to represent a
unitary and you plug that into a phase
estimation circuit and that phase
estimation circuit will give you a way
of estimating the eigenvalues sometimes
you'd like to be able to learn the
expectation values of observables
normally the way that you'll want to do
that is you'll set up some circuit like
a Hadamard test or something like that
that will be able to give you indirectly
the expectation value of that observable
and then you just run an algorithm like
amplitude estimation on top of it in
order to be able to figure out that
expectation value inexpensively but a
final one that often is ended at that
people often will use is they'll wanna
know the distance between different
quantum states and the easiest way to do
that is to apply the standard circuit
called the swamp test so for the output
there's a bunch of things that you can
end up doing after you get the quantum
state back out in order to be able to
extract things of physical meaning so
let me talk about the first method for a
compilation this is the perhaps from at
least from a physicists perspective
is the most the most natural way to
simulate Hamiltonian dynamics and this
is Charter Suzuki methods so the basic
idea is that imagine we've got you know
Hamiltonian that's a sum of these terms
over here and I make no sum I don't need
to make any assumptions about the
unitary here but in any case the basic
idea behind this is that what you do is
you say alright let's the time evolution
operator is the exponential of the sum
of all of these individual terms now if
all of these terms commuted then what
I'd be able to do is I'd be able to say
oh well I can express the exponential to
sum as a product of each of these
individual terms now if each of those H
J's is simple like say a poly operator
then we can design easy circuits to
handle each and every one of those guys
and then that's how we do the simulation
now in practice of course they don't
commute so there's errors that end up
coming in and that's what these errors
over here represent and so then the
tactic behind charter Suzuki formulas is
what you do is use a stroboscopic
approach for simulation what you do is
you break up your time evolution into a
series of our time slices and by making
our shorter and shorter and shorter you
can make those commutator airs smaller
and smaller and smaller and eventually
end up making the air 0 so that's the
idea behind it you take your Hamiltonian
as a sum of easy terms over here that
you know how to individually simulate
and then use the Trotters the Charter
Suzuki decomposition in order to break
it up into a sequence of those easy to
simulate terms rather than an
exponential to sum that you wouldn't
know how to do directly all right and so
basically the idea is that if you look
at the simplest formula for this we you
end up finding that it ends up scaling
like 1 over R so you need a number of
slices that would scale quadratically
with the evolution time which it'll work
but it really sucks to be honest so you
can get around this by using higher
order formula over here that which can
be recursively derived from the
symmetric form of that and this this
sucks less but it's still not it's not
still not devoid of suck so the point is
is that you know when we end up using
this what we end up getting is we end up
getting a complexity that scales by
optimizing a value of K that we have for
this we end up getting something at
scale super linearly with the evolution
time T all right now the problem is is
that the actual limit the fundamental
limit that you can end up getting for
this is linear in T so there's a sub
polynomial but not poly logarithmic bit
of this over here that is left over and
so these methods formally speaking are
not optimal which is emit which is a
drawback another problem is that the
error bounds that we can end up proving
for these formulas are they're concise
they're easy to use but they really blow
so to give you an idea about how awful
these error bounds are is these are some
of the best error bounds that I knew
open when we did the nitrogen a
simulation paper up here these are the
values that we computed using upper
bounds on the air in a charter Suzuki
formula for the complexity of simulation
and these are numerical results using
the exact values they're loose by a
factor of about 10,000 and so and and
bear in mind that the at least at the
time those are the best known bounds
that were available yep so the what
that's based on is that's based on a
Hamiltonian that it can be used in order
to compute parity so what you do is you
design this Hamiltonian that could
compute parity and you show that if you
were able to use simulate this evolution
of the Hamiltonian faster than linear in
T then what would happen is you'd be
able to with fewer queries then you
require in order to solve the parity
problem you'd be able to solve it so
it's a proof by contradiction
but also it would be very surprising in
general if you could get you know
polynomial yeah yeah so okay that's one
of the things that is hard about it one
of the things though that is I think
actually really kind of neat though
about about these charter Suzuki
formulas is that the air ends up varying
with the commutator 's not the size of
the Hamiltonian so for example if the if
all the terms in a Hamiltonian commute
there is no air in a charter Suzuki
decomposition and it becomes a stupidly
efficient method for for simulation
whereas the other methods that I'm going
to be talking about don't have this
property so that is that's one of the
reasons why charter Suzuki formulas
intuitively despite the fact that the
air bounds are awful actually might be
pretty awesome and so the other things
that I should mention is that similar
bounds for the fourth order formulas for
local hamiltonians have been shown to
this this general one for the second or
third order formula depending on how you
count and also another thing that's
quite interesting about it is this
recent result that Andrew and some other
people worked on which addresses the
question of how you should order terms
in your Trotter Suzuki decomposition and
so intuitively it might it it might seem
that if you randomized between every one
of your steps the ordering of the terms
then the errors may cancel out in some
advantageous way and well people you
know if people had looked at this
informally in the past this result ends
up showing it in some circumstances you
can actually do quadratically better in
terms of your scaling by randomization
so that's that's a pretty cool result I
think and shows that really even though
the Charter Suzuki seems like in
instance in some ways it's suboptimal
there's a lot of gas left in this tank
so with that formula the bottom is for
is I believe the number of gates that
are required for the simulation
all right so now let me let me talk
about linear combinations of unit Ares
methods in the increasingly shortening
amount of time that I've got so the idea
basically is that let's say you want to
do a simulation you don't know about
trotter formulas
what's the dumbest thing that you could
possibly consider to do you might say oh
I know what I'm going to do is I'm going
to just write out the Taylor series for
e to the minus IHT and implement that on
a quantum computer right how hard could
that be
well there's one minor problem with that
and the problem is is that if you
truncate the Taylor series of finite
order it's not a unitary and since
quantum computers naturally do unit Ares
how do you do this well turns out
there's a gadget for doing this that
looks like this and basically the
probability of success ends up scaling
like 1 over this sum over here and by
choosing the one norm of these
coefficients times T to be equal to log
2 you can make the probability of
success anything you want and if you can
make a probability of success anything
you want the answer is always 1/4 okay
you might want one but 1/4 is the next
best thing the reason why is because at
1/4 you can use amplitude amplification
to boost that probability of success to
100% with one iteration and so that's
the basic idea behind this method you
use this get non-deterministic gadget to
to implement the some of those unitary
matrices you you choose the evolution
time in each segment of it to satisfy
this probability success approximately
1/4 and then you use amplitude
amplification to boost it the rest of
the way and that's how that's how these
methods end up working so it's in many
ways this complexity is much nicer than
charter Suzuki it ends up scaling
linearly well near linearly with Qi and
it ends up scaling logarithmically as
opposed to sub polynomial e with 1 over
Epsilon and that's that's something
that's really awesome but another thing
that's great is that you can also
simulate time to time dependent
evolution with this so if your
Hamiltonian is explicitly time dependent
you can also do it using this formula
'sm so but something is very neat about
this is because of the
that what you can do is you can slice up
the evolution into a sum of different
unit Ares and then use an exponential
superposition over those unit Ares you
can give yourself effectively an
exponential number of time steps in that
superposition that you're doing in a
single step and that gives you a fast
way of kind of doing a Monte Carlo
approximation to this unitary up at the
top over there and because of you
because you have this ability to do an
exponential number of time steps
essentially with us that ends up giving
you a complexity that in the end only
scales logarithmically of the maximum
derivative in contrast if you were to
try to do the same thing with trotter
formulas it would scale like the square
root of this that means unitary means e
to the minus IHT okay H is not unitary H
was given as a sum of unitary so H what
I could but for some of these methods of
what I would need to do if I just took
it i give me the most extreme cases i
could take it to be itself right and
then i would still need some method in
order to decompose the problem the
simulation problem into a sequence of
simple simulation problems that I can
then compile onto a quantum computer and
so I would still need to do in some ways
a decomposition of the Hamiltonian into
simpler objects with us so for these
methods over here for the linear
combinations of unit Ares I'd have to
choose some class of elementary unit
Ares to decompose them into for other
methods I wouldn't need to do that but
for this one I would and and I should
mention I said e to the minus IHT here
that's formally not true I mean a time
evolution operator because this is for a
time-dependent Hamiltonian ever thing
they've done
but the Hamiltonian is self-adjoint to
hermitian but by writing there's a Summa
communitary that enables his methodology
its cleverness it's in the service of
his methodology but I mean these forms
are livid Beauty equal to that Sam works
well but he's trying to get he has a
technique for simulation which is
enabled by writing the Hamiltonian as
some of you helps isn't it yeah that's
exactly it
so yeah you you just want to do this
because the problem of simulation is a
compilation problem what we want to do
is we want to take some complicated
dynamics break it up into a sequence of
simpler problems that we know how to
solve and you know all of those at some
level involve applying a unitary so it's
just a question of where you want to
draw that line really so the complexity
of the prepare and select you see that
that that depends very strongly on the
particular case that you're looking at
so in general the cost of preparing
doing to prepare because there's m
coefficients you've got to put in
obviously if there's no Pat structure
whatsoever to those the complexity of
that has to be poly a polynomial in M
but what the deal is is that and with
select in general you know if the the
worst case is if you've got no structure
you have to have just one control for
every single possible term in the
Hamiltonian but often with the sorts of
problem the circuits that we end up
looking at there's a lot of structure to
that so we find that often the cost
typically will be much less than that
but yeah in general in general the the
cost is going to be polynomial in a
number of terms in a Hamiltonian but the
key point is with this over here is
because the Hamiltonian evolve evaluated
each of these individual times it has a
lot of structure between it what you can
often end up doing is you
use the structure in order to reduce the
number of the the complexity of that
query so it becomes actually logarithmic
in the number of time steps that you end
up using here rather than polynomial so
this ends up leading to this this new
result that we're I'm happy about but
I'm nearly out of time so I'll just skim
through it really quick basic idea is
that because for some of these methods
with linear combinations of unit Ares
the cost of the in terms of the
derivatives is logarithmic rather than
linear what you can do is you can use
this transformation to an interaction
picture in order to take big terms from
the Hamiltonian and switch them into the
derivatives of a time-dependent
Hamiltonian that simulates a time
independent Hamiltonian and so by doing
this what we can do is we can reduce the
cost of simulating diagonally dominant
hamiltonians dramatically in some cases
exponentially so that's basically the
idea here's some theorems that I don't
have time to talk about ok cubed ization
final thing which I also don't have time
to talk about basically the idea behind
cubed ization is to take a quantum walk
that whose eigenvalues are about a that
are related to the eigenvalues of the
Hamiltonian that you want to simulate
then what this quantum walk operator is
defined in terms of a reflection times
the select operation that I talked about
and so when you go through that you end
up finding that basically the
eigenvalues of this over here in each
two dimensional subspace that you're
that this walk operator acts on ends up
being just the arc cosine of the
eigenvalues times a sigma y operator and
so when you expand this all the way out
you can see that this ends up simulating
e to the IARC coasts of the Hamiltonian
basically then basically the rest of
this technique just involves going
through and using this technique in
order to remap the eigenvalues using a
polynomial transformation into the
eigenvalues of the real one because
you'd want to get rid of that Arcos and
this formula over here allows you to
introduce a bunch of Bessel functions
and a Fourier series essentially that
will end up implementing that
yeah sorry about that I ran out of time
yeah oh we got time Andrew alright cool
well thank you for pulling me back then
alright cool okay so this this wall of
text alright so let me let me try again
with my now and now empowered time
budget so basically what the idea is is
that in in this context what we want to
do is we really want to this this boils
down to a lot of intuition that Andrew
had one of his earlier papers which is
the the fact that quantum walks are
equivalent to a Hamiltonian simulation
so the idea is is that what for one part
of that proof what you need to show is
you need to show that for every
Hamiltonian there ends up existing a
quantum walk for it and so the way that
one way you can end up doing this is by
constructing a walk operator W as I call
it over here which ends up basically
being equivalent up to an isometry to
the to the original Hamiltonian that you
want to simulate and this the way that
this walk ends up working is it involves
a reflection about this state L and the
state L over here is really just that
state that I talked about that encodes
the amplitudes of the various terms in
the Hamiltonian and select what it does
is it really just applies HL to each of
those now if each of these H else is
unitary and hermitian then this also is
a reflection operator so that basically
is the the idea behind it so we apply
this over here and it may at first
glance seem totally uh knob vyas how
this has any connection whatsoever to
Hamiltonian simulation and the
connection really ends up coming in and
that in this matrix that that I was
describing over here what you can for
for walks of this form the the walk
operation boils down to a
some over two dimensional irreducible
subspaces okay
so in order to diagonalize the wok
operator it suffice is to look at each
of these individual subspaces and this
is an example of what one of those
subspaces ends up looking like when you
when you rip it away so these eks over
here are the eigenvalues of the
hamiltonian lamda is the if if you
recall over here is defined to be just
the sum of the in general absolute
values of each of these coefficients of
the Hamiltonian and so you can see hey
wait a second that looks just like a
like a Sigma Y rotation and so that's
what I wrote over here this is just the
Sigma Y rotation that is equivalent to
that two-dimensional matrix over there
when you break it up into these little
blocks okay so you can see yeah so the
blocks over here the way that that I end
up defining them is I say okay let's
take a look at the action of W on one of
the eigenvectors of it so I want to be
able to take an eigenvector of the LH
and see what it ends up what space it
ends up mapping that on to so that forms
a that forms an irreducible
two-dimensional space in it and and that
irreducible two-dimensional space can be
mapped as this
they're mapping to the state orthogonal
in that two-dimensional space to it so
yeah exactly so no this is all for
analysis this is just to give you an
idea about how you how you can construct
this walk operator which then which then
gives you a method to do the Hamiltonian
simulation right so the idea basically
is that you can see you can see that
this is has exactly the same eigen
values well plus minus because the eigen
values of Y but it's got the exact same
eigen values is the original Hamiltonian
but art coast and renormalized so if
you've had a way to undo the arc cosine
then you'd be able to turn this into a
general-purpose simulation method now
the original method that was proposed to
do this was phase estimation so if you
just applied phase estimation to this
you could learn the the eigenvalues
coherently and then you'd be able to
invert using ideas like the harrowhouse
and and Lloyd algorithm but there's a
slicker approach that can be used and
that's this Jacobian gur formula over
here and basically with that as I said
ends up doing is it ends up allowing you
to get rid of or introduce an arcs a
sign up at the top as a sum of this and
so by doing that and putting in a face
shift on it you can get a cosign which
ends up inverting the R cosign and gives
you exactly the evolution that you want
so this formula coupled with either
linear combinations of unit Ares or this
technique called Quantum signal
processing that Guangzhou and others
invented give you a method for doing
this
so that's how that's how this method
called qubit ization works so to
conclude
yeah I guess
the yeah actually there's one other
thing I should discuss which is the
truncate the order that you're
truncating at basically the cost of this
it turns out to be is essentially just
the order that you truncate this
jacobian or expansion at out at and this
one over here is super awesome the
reason why it's super awesome is because
it actually saturates the lower bound on
on quantum simulation it's lit it scales
linearly with the evolution time and it
scales
additively with this part over here
which exactly matches the lower bounds
that we know for quantum simulation so
this is fantastic and from a theoretical
perspective it seems like at first
glance it should be what you always do
for for simulation and so this leads to
my final slide which is why are we still
talking about things because we've got
the optimal we've got the optimal
solution but it turns out that actually
sometimes optimal is an optimal one of
the challenges with with the qubit at
qubit ization approach is that there's
no natural way to simulate time
dependence so if you got a
time-dependent Hamiltonian it doesn't
actually naturally fit into that
framework without putting a clock
register and exponentially large
Hamiltonians and it's just a pain and
nobody's figured a good way of making it
work efficiently and that rules out
doing things like the interaction
picture simulation that I was talking
about so that's a that's a big
deficiency that we that we have at the
moment in our simulation methods the
other thing that's actually quite
interesting and this is this is a figure
taken from a paper that Andrew did with
yong-su Maslov and some other people but
basically what happened out of this is
these PFS over here these are Trotter
formulas at the top and bounce that you
they end up getting from it versus the
empirical results that they end up
seeing down here and again one of the
things that's interesting is that
quantum signal processing which
basically is equivalent to the method
that I showed previously you'd expect
that would be the best asymptotically
but in practice it looks like trotter
formulas often end up beating it and one
of there's a lot of questions about why
why do Trotter form
beating this well we know that there's
this asymmetry because commutator Zend
up coming in but getting a good
intuition for how exactly those
commutator czar providing these
advantages is challenging furthermore
getting expect expressions for high
order Trotter formulas that involve
commutator z' for the air bounce is
exceedingly hard and it would be great
if we could figure out ways of
extracting that information to figure
out how good are higher order variants
you know if the fourth order formula
does as well what about this what about
what about the sixth what about the 8th
so on and so forth we don't really have
a good idea because Trotter formulas are
hard to take a look at similarly one of
the things that you know and this also
leads into Ryan's talk later on is that
well we've got I've talked entirely
about simulation in the abstract there's
a lot that's left to be done in the
particular such as how do we come up
with the best circuits for simulating
important problems like quantum
chemistry other work that people like
Robin and Jim Wong have done have looked
at simulating particular problems of
local Hammel interactions and these
models actually can be substantially
easier to simulate then you might
naively think when you take a look at
these results so there's a lot of work
left to be done in applying these ideas
in precise and and creative ways to
actual problems that we're interested in
seeing and then finally there's this
question that I think still needs some
investigation which is while all of this
is talking about closed system dynamics
well there's been some great progress in
simulating open quantum systems in the
form of Lindblad ii and simulation
methods there's a lot that needs to be
done you can't just hand somebody a set
of arbitrary Crouse operators for
example and ask what's the complexity of
this and I really think that quantum
simulation should get to the point where
we can address questions like that
questions like what is the complexity of
simulating the standard model there are
many things that we just don't know
about simulation and I'm hoping that
well within the next few years and
hopefully by bringing more people into
the field with diverse perspectives that
we can get answers to them thank you
very much
[Applause]
so you're right here that the three of
us prominent methods are Trotter [ __ ]
Taylor series and suit ization but I'm
curious are there actually any
situations in which the Taylor series
method would be better than qubit
ization it seems like it as sort of all
the flaws Cubans Asian business yes yeah
yeah you know and that that was sort of
my take on it for a while I was kind of
bummed because I spent you know we both
spent a long time looking at truncated
Taylor series and it didn't seem to be
performing all that well which is why I
which is why I I'm super pumped about
the interaction frame thing because of
the fact that in order to get the
advantages of simulating diagonally
dominant hamiltonians using a technique
you've got to go to time-dependent
simulation and that's one of the things
that truncated to a Taylor does a great
job at it's awesome for time dependent
simulations okay so you're including the
Dyson series yeah yeah you should be
truncated Dyson series more formally but
yes for odorous uzuki you can everything
now when you start piling the actual
kids saying I hope you do member majse
combination also and alike
or the pointy-toe subcircuit does any
work or theory these two so when it
comes to the use of say randomize
compiling as a particular example I mean
from my perspective the main application
of that really is to end up decreasing
the amount of unitarity in your errors
if you care about what the gap is
between the bounds that you end up
getting for the diamond norm difference
and what you get from randomized
benchmarking there's been some
discussion about this but I I think that
the two communities at the moment who
care about these sorts of issues are a
little disparate right now but the use
of either the use of either randomize
compiling or you know if you feel like
going back to the 70s and the NMR
literature just dynamical decoupling you
know that I think is probably going to
be a tool that we'll want to use in
general but specifying it for simulation
I don't think anybody's looked at
oh that's what you mean I'm sorry yeah I
mean there are there are different ways
that you can end up doing it one way
that you can end up doing it is on the
outer inference loop for example say
you're running phase estimation by using
more advanced phase estimation
techniques what you can do is you can
take advantage of the fact that you know
that there's noise in the system and
learn the quantities that you want out
of the you learn a small signal out of a
lot of noise other approaches that tend
to work better for situations where
you've got a lot of noise is you want to
have as low depth of a Circuit as you
possibly can and for these techniques
like variational quantum eigen solvers
have some element of robustness to these
sorts of these sorts of problems but
they also have you know challenges about
large numbers of measurements and high
variances that can sometimes also be an
issue so you know it it's not-- there's
no free lunch but there are things that
they're definitely things that you can
do outside of what I mentioned here to
deal with it
sure um really none basically the
problem of simulating quantum chemistry
is really just you're simulating you're
simulating a many-body fermionic system
so it's it really the Hamiltonian often
looks identical to what you're looking
at in a electronic structure in
particular but you know it depends on
the system that you're looking at from
my perspective many-body physics is more
general then you know solving some
electronic structure problem with
fermions so but you can see this all is
kind of under the same umbrella the
techniques look very very similar at the
end of the day well it's the thing is is
that quantum chemistry I mean the the
only thing that makes it I guess more
specific is the form of where the
individual coefficients for the creation
and annihilation operators in the
description of your Hamiltonian ends up
coming where they end up arising from so
that's from my perspective the only
difference between that and other
applications in electronic structure
some of these problems will have quoted
quadratically fewer terms though that's
one of the big things like if you're
looking at something like a Hubbard
model for example or if you're
interested in some materials problem
that you're analyzing in like a plane
way basis then the form of the
Hamiltonian can be substantially simpler
but yeah it's so I see it as
specialization but from the perspective
of this talk it's all they're all
instantiations the same global idea
yeah yeah so the question about the
initial state is I should mention that
that's actually one of the from the
perspective of simulation that's one of
the biggest open questions in general if
say we want to solve some problem like
ground state estimation like the you
know the previous talk was discussing in
order to be able to do that we need to
prepare a surrogate ground state for for
the system and we don't know the
complexity of preparing a ground state
that has a high overlap with the actual
physical ground state so that's one of
the reasons why I intentionally spent
very little time talking about this
because formally I don't really know
what to say about the complexity of
preparing ground states other than the
fact that you know in general it's like
a you know for many body problems as qma
art yeah sure you know I'm sure Scott
Scott yeah I empathized this with that
argument over there but I think that
there is reason because if nature can
actually find its way into these ground
states then that would be a profoundly
interesting realization because I I'm
not fully I'm not fully convinced
although I'd like to believe that in I'm
not fully convinced by the quantum
church-turing thesis it is conceivable
that there could be physics that that
exists in nature which may give the
world greater computational power than a
quantum computer so that would be
profoundly interesting if it were the
case but of course no counter example
has been seen so far so
if you don't believe in that that we
don't believe in her
well alright great let me be clear I
don't believe in physics no I'm serious
yes yes yes I'm a hundred percent
serious I do not believe in physics the
what I believe is I believe that over
the centuries we've developed
exceptionally good models for describing
some things that we care about in the
world I do not believe an electron goes
around and stores in some register a
description of its quantum state that it
updates with a pencil and paper in order
to figure out how it evolves these are
models that we've learned and they are
just that there is nothing deeper
they're extremely good models but I
don't believe in the reality of physics
personally I don't think we have to all
we need to do is be able to simulate the
mathematical models they're useful for
us to describe the things we see around
us it doesn't have to be true doesn't
have to be right it just has to be
useful in that sphere another argument
you could make for ground states is to
say well who cares about you know just
simulating what nature does why not tell
nature what it should be doing you know
in some extent you know there was a lot
of work that was done in the past and
you know laser chemistry and things like
this that was kind of telling nature
what to do and that from that
perspective but yeah
okay we'll give you on that been deleted
[Applause]